dico la verità ragazzi questa è una
storiella abbastanza easy però ora devo
assolutamente raccontare bene a tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo l'episodio
di rocket league dove cerco di non fare
cagate nel mentre che racconta storielle
vi fa mi fa piacere che ultimamente sto
prende l'abitudine papi in toscana e nel
punto dove dove sta dove alloggiavo ecco
diciamo che non eravamo troppo lontani
dall umbria ok la toscana confine con
l'umbria allo scoperto
l'ho scoperto un mese fantastico bello
imparare la geografia sulla propria
pelle bello imparare la geografia sulla
propria pelle questa cosa incredibile
eravamo vicinissimi un giorno di quelli
in cui sono stato in toscana abbiamo
deciso con questa persona e degli amici
da dare in umbria abbiamo preso
stamattina siamo andati in umbria cerati
precisamente in un posto che si chiama
castiglion del lago castiglion del lago
che tra l'altro un posto della madonna
c'era un vento incredibile però era
veramente figo cioè posto pazzesco si
mangi si è mangiato da paura tanto mi
ricordo che nel paesino vendevano i
delle cose chiamate tipo le palle del
nonno che tu dici ma che è che vendono
le palle del nonno in macelleria novi si
vede che è una cosa che si chiama così
però sarà un piatto tipico umbro
credo non lo so ma è comunque ben de
rose valle del nome andiamo sul lago sul
lago c'è questa spiaggetta molto molto
carina dove puoi godere tutta la vista
del lago finissimo poi inizia la storia
il giorno prima io non avevo dormito da
un altro cielo proprio voto ambito la
mazza lei nata sulle tre quattro ore che
per me se io do 17 ore invece che otto
sono uno zombie ok se norma tre o
quattro
diciamo che il mio corpo ormai lo
conosco e so come reagisce quando si
dorme poco semplicemente io non mi
concentro sulle cose 6 quando tra un po
che non riesco a concentrarmi sulle cose
non mi ricordo bene le robe non sono
concentrato che insomma poi tutto figo
tutto bello tutto fotomodello torniamo
in toscana perché abbiamo
pomeriggio la paio d'ore saremmo stati
ma neanche forse anche meno un'oretta e
mezza su una spiaggia e poi siamo
tornati in toscana entro nel mio albergo
per così dire faccio per prepararmi
perché era quasi ora di cena aprendo le
robe mi vesto cerco madonna è parlato
affatto preparo per uscire prendo
telefono power line tutte robe e poi
faccio per prendere il portafoglio non
c'era il portafoglio di ci voleva come
com'è possibile che non c'è portavoce
lavoro lasciato vicino al comodino
guardo sul comodino non c'è guardo sul
tavolo non c'è guardo sul letto non c'è
insomma sto portafoglio non si trova o
inc in macchina dove lo mettiamo
siamo andati non c'è insomma non voleva
salta fuori stavolta voglio con i pochi
neuroni rimasti cerco di capire dove
possa essere finito ho detto che vuoi
vedere che l'ho perso sulla spiaggia in
umbria sono stato due ore in umbria e in
due ore io ho perso il portafogli in
ombra in due o due ore 22 enne che dici
sono stato di voli e da un po non due
ore in umbria per sul portafoglio ok
sostato due ori in umbria ha perso il
portafoglio di ipotesi perché poi non
sapevo
magari nella più scivolato non lo so
però è l'ipotesi di averlo perso perché
comunque mi ero seduto sulla spiaggia
magari me la scivolata in quel momento
come fa scivolato in portafoglio mentre
sei seduto non lo so però baba a capire
che nei topi
niente cosa faccio io l'ho cercato per
un'oretta e poi a un certo punto mi sono
completamente rassegnato completamente
se io mi sono fermato e ho detto vabbè
tanto mi conosco so chi sono
so che il portafoglio hanno perso e so
che qualsiasi persona nel mondo quando
perde qualcosa dopo venti minuti 30
un'oretta massimo che la cerca la trova
io so di essere io e quindi so che quel
portafoglio volente o nolente non
salterà mai fuori mai quindi io so di
averlo perso e quindi non era né a chi
cazzato ero avevo accettato il fatto di
averlo perso amen
pazienza l'ho perso poi ho dovuto ogni
giorno dopo sarei dovuto tornare a casa
a milano non avevo più il portafoglio
con dentro i soldi la carta d'identità
ovviamente che aveva riperso perché
certo figuriamo dal video in cui ho
detto che ho
adesso la carta d'identità tre volte
adesso l'ho persa una quarta volta
ragazzi fantastico giorno dopo mi
squilla il telefono e sapete che nei
telefoni violenza ma tutti devono i
moderni quando ti si chiama qualcuno
compare adesso la scritta sotto di dove
ti sta chiamando vedo che il telefono mi
squilla numero sconosciuto umbria come
lecco la parola umbria
io mi smith mi tuffo ti faccia sul
telefono e rispondo
fatemi finire la partita che ormai è
concitata vediamo quanto a finire se
pure vinta vis
pensate se non mi impegnavo d'altra
parte sento lorenzo siamo i carabinieri
il lorenzo siamo i carabinieri di
castiglion del lago
la colonna sonora della mia vita
buongiorno sono io quello che perde il
portafoglio siete voi quelli le persone
che un giorno molto probabilmente anzi
sicuramente andranno in paradiso mi
rispondono guarda ci hanno portato il
tuo portafoglio con tutti i soldi dentro
tra l'altro dentro c'erano 160 euro
tantissimi ma detto al trovato il
portafoglio con tutto dentro viene
riprende insomma siamo ripartiti dalla
toscana che mandati in umbria per la
millesima volta solo per natale di
prendere il portafoglio salgo
nell'ufficio dei carabinieri buongiorno
sei tu quello che perde sono io sono io
sei tu quello youtubers sono io sono io
ma giorni appena scorso a noi cosa è uno
mi ha fatto questa domanda non sto
scherzando di uno studio poi comunque ho
firmato poi tutta roba non ci credo
perché poi magari sai cos'è perché
magari qualcuno non ci crede allora io
cosa faccio genio io vi faccio vedere il
modulo che ciò ancora qua nel
portafoglio dei carabinieri di
castiglion del lago temi hanno compilato
polizia locale comune di castiglion del
lago parco del demonio morto io ho perso
il portafoglio in quelle due cazzotti
ore che sono stato in umbria dal set in
conclusione devo fare questa volontà io
credo credo perché io perdo sempre
portafoglio che l'ho perso quattro volte
nell'ultimo anno e settimo killing in
una 365 giorni io ho perso quattro volte
il portafoglio ok delle quali tre di
queste volte al mio portafoglio vecchio
poi la terza volta non l'ho più
ritrovato lorenzo mio manager mi ha
regalato questo portafoglio e mi ha
detto mi raccomando non perderlo come
gli altri tre quanto quanto mi è durato
cielo ancora per adesso quello perderlo
ovviamente di nuovo però adesso ce l'ho
ancora mi è durato mela rigatone agli
scorso e che mi regalano i portafogli a
natale ok la gente mi legali portafogli
a natale ok portafoglio di prima che ho
perso tre volte me lo avevano regalato
il natale scorso e io in un mese l'ho
perso tre volte tre fino a che non lo
più ritrovato e ho continuato a
utilizzare il mio vecchio ok lorenzo mi
ha regalato questo a questo natale e mi
fa non perderlo io nel giro di un mese
lo penso quindi io credo di avere una
maledizione per il portafogli che mi
regala la gente ce ne il mio porta il
mio portafoglio non l'ho mai perso in
dieci anni quelli il portafoglio che vi
regali i portafogli che mi regalano le
altre persone io li perdo li perdo senza
motivo li perdo io perdo i portafogli
che la gente mi dà senso ma giuro su dio
cioè se io avessi il mio portafoglio non
l'avrei mai perso in umbria però se il
portafoglio e di una
persona che me l'ha regalato io lo perdo
quindi mi guardate guarda il mio
bellissimo portafoglio vedete questo bel
portafoglio
guardatelo bene perché tra un po non
vedrete più questa è stata la quarta
volta in cui l'ho perso il portafoglio
ci aggiorniamo poi per la quinta ragazzi
iscritti al canale schiacciata la
campanellina prima e ragionati suoi
video che escono perché non vorrete
parte di la quinta volta in cui lo
perderò iron associate lo perderò cioè
non è non è che lo sto dicendo tanto
perché io so che lo perdo perché è
proprio garantito che se qualcuno vi
regala un portafoglio di lo perdo quindi
io lo riperde rowe adesso prevede
prevedo di comprare su amazon se riesco
dei gps da piccard e dentro il
portafoglio in modo tale che quando lo
perde lo saprò dove è finito e quindi vi
facevamo un video blog live di io che
vado a recuperare il mio portafoglio ma
tanto non so già che lo farò quindi non
vedo l'ora
soprattutto dai ragazzi questo era
quella volta che ripensi portafoglio e
tanto 2020 version
spero che vi sia piaciuto come più vi
piace iscritti al canale scrivete un
commento secondo voi su dove lo perderò
la prossima volta perché si accettano
scommesse
e noi come sempre ci rivediamo al
prossimo oggetto smarrito bella ragazza
[Musica]